Bonsoir M. Ugeux.
- Bonsoir.
- Cette mes s s s s s s s s s st
que certaines institutions
financières russes.
Qu'est-ce que les pays
occiprécisément?
GEORGES UGEUX, ancien vice-
président, bourse de New York
- Il chercha à empêcher qu'
laquelle la Russie ne fournirait
d d d d d'énergie et l'Europe e
serait plus en mesure de lannnnn
intervention SWIFT à des grandes
banques, et le paiement qui
fait avec des entreprises vapoue
qui permettra de maintenir
l'approvisionnement de
Pour le faire de manière à la
fois efficace.
- On a beaucoup s s s s s s s ss
peut-être plus importantes, ce
sont les mesures annoncées qui
visent la banque centrale russe.
- Oui, c'est extrêmement
important, parce qu'on dit
toujours que les réserves russes
sont importardrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrdrs
sont maintenues par la banque
centrale à travers des comptes
en plusieurs devises. Cet argent
là va été partiellement gelé. Et
c'est exactement ce qu'elle a
dit dans le reportage, qu'onchca
Russie, on cherche à étrangler
l'esesesesesesesesesesesesesesee
maintenant on va limiter la
possibilité de la Russie de
fa
réserves pour financer la gare.
- Et on veut réduire aussi
russe au marché des capitaux
pour empêcher Moscou de sou
le cours du rouble, en recul
suite à la gare en Ukraine.
en raison de la banque centrale.
Ceci dit, le rouble est au p
bas de toute son histoire par
rapport au dollar. Les mesures
précédentes ont déjà eu un effet
extrêmement important, à la foi,
sur le rouble, que sur le
- Comment la Russie va financer
son effort de guerre?
devoir avoir besoin
d'équipement, elle va avoir
nombre de ses fournisseurs. Ce
qu'elle achetait, notamment, des
autre problème dans la Russie,
80 % de l'eseseseseseseseses pis
de rechange qui vienne en dehors
de Russie. Donc la Russie est
extrêmement dépendante pour
cela, d'avoir un système de
paiement qui soit tout à fait
libre. Et le fait que tout le
monddédédédédédédédédédécision
de l'étrangler sauf pour le
avis la bonne solution. Mais ça
va faire mal parce
t t t t t t t t t t l'énergie va
coûter plus cher.
- Mais ce sera efficace selon
vous pour tenter d'arrêter cette
- Je crois qu'on ne peut pas
espérer avoir un impact, arrêter
plplplplplplplplplplement par ct
très difficile pour le président
Poutine.ntntntntntntntntntntntre
rendre compte que l'alternative
par rapport à ces m